sur son promontoire telle une place
forte entre l'os et montrichard
le château de montpoupon n'a aucun
secret pour son responsable touristique
mathieu bibard qui a commencé ici comme
stagiaire en 2004 donc là où nous allons
accéder au premier étage nous allons
monter dans la chambre du roy qui est
vraiment la chambre emblématique de
montpon une des chambres les plus belles
du château très lumineuse avec du
mobilier renaissance je vous invite à
monter au premier étage
la particularité de cette chambre ces
plafonds pas mal italienne sa table à
rallonger son coffre a créé danse
d'origine représentatif du mobilier de
la cour itinérante du début du xvième
siècle
[Musique]
tous les chatrier d'une chambre haut de
gamme pour accueillir le roi c'était un
peu une obligation contrepartie pour
construire un château il fallait
l'autorisation du roi et si celui ci
était amené à passer dans votre demeure
on devait loger le nourrir forcément on
va loger dans une chambre à la hauteur
du roi en montant au second étage le
visiteur fait un bond dans le temps
direction le début du 20e siècle et les
appartements privés de la famille de la
mode saint-pierre propriétaire du
château
jusqu'en 2005
solange tu vois j'ai laissé ici tout est
joué quand tu étais petit
il ne rappelle tellement de souvenirs
solange de la motte saint pierre est un
personnage emblématique de montpoupon
c'est notamment elle qu'il l'a ouvert au
public en 1960 et vous qu'elle savait
parlait cinq langues
elle a beaucoup voyagé elle a créé la
chambre d'agriculture la société
archéologique de touraine dans lequel
aussi elle était entreprenante même des
gîtes ruraux qu'elle a commencé à créer
dans les années 70 sur le domaine de
bonbons avec les anciennes fermes
elle avait commencé à développer aussi à
montpon des survols en hélicoptère donc
vous imaginez pour l'époque c'était si
novateur solange de la motte saint
pierre était aussi une excellente
cavalière est une adepte de la chasse à
courre il faut dire que sa famille
possédait un des équipages les plus
importants de france
donc la vénerie implantée à mon profond
depuis plusieurs siècles mais surtout
depuis 1873 à peu près où il ya eu la
création d'un équipage de chasse qui est
l équipage de montpoupon qui a été créée
par emile de la mode saint pierre au
départ l'équipage chasser le chevreuil
et à la fin du 19ème début du 20e siècle
équipes achats sera le sert également de
cette histoire familiale est né le musée
du bonheur et ses 30 salle dédiée à la
chasse à courre et au métier qui
l'entourent
il fait partie des quatre grands musées
de la chasse en france